and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bomb
tonight's review Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles oh my dad easy - greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
no spoilers no spoilers Go Go spoilers
no spoilers go near these churches who
are ninjas and they were experimented on
Anna scientists was a little girl named
April Neil who fed the pizza and named a
method a Renaissance artists which ya
little girl who's gonna grow up in to
make him fat we know their innocence
artists I only know what the artist
formerly known as Prince
but that Abra Tory was burned down and
the little girl helps them escape into
the store where they grow up doing
mostly nothing but making in jokes -
you're mutants who are teenagers and
turtles and ninjas but it sounds silly
when you put in a debt so your aliens
know they'd be even stupider wink wink
hey bro
you're gonna help me with my hip-hop
Christmas album Oh Mikey only a
franchise that doesn't know when this
stuff would do something it's silly is
that in the 80s or 90s
so April grows up and starts working for
a pointless Whoopi Goldberg cameo on the
pilots will be Goldberg cameo and tries
to talk about these giant turtles she's
been seeing - an unfunny Will Arnett hi
I'm unfunny we learned it how come
you're not funny anymore
I used it all up in the lego movie but
this is evil scientist called Eric and
he's working for the evil shudder who's
just a big jerk who wants to take over
the world unlike the original shredder
who is just a big jerk who wanted to
take over the world but we had a cooler
way he liked to ride around in a giant
metal white testicle deny on top of it
this show was weird so let's try to
fight the turtles hideout and he turns
himself into the most diabolical evil
thing you can imagine
penis envy shredder I am a giant car
engine that shoots an eye dude you look
like Michael Bay's kidneys dude so you
four are pretty much just mud flats and
skins now I want to be your rap master
with my dry robotic body one of the foot
soldiers to feel with their guns I don't
let your shootie thingies you know for a
movie Co Ninja Turtles there's not
listening Jitsu in it we'll just say
hi-yah once or twice shotgun keys
to try to capture three of them it
destroys their whole home and buy a
whole home I mean a small little part in
the middle of the home
Raphael climbs out of the rubble because
again they just blew up a small part in
the middle of the home and he's like I
gotta believe in teamwork again to get
my brothers back wait was that ever an
issue for you kinda we mentioned it once
maybe twice it's okay I'm supposed to be
the one you're always supposed to say
but actually I think I saved you guys
more than you save me well that doesn't
sound too bad for you it will be except
that I'm boring as Brett that's true so
is revealing in a turtle's blood they
have a cure for the disease this disease
ever gonna spread throughout New York
and then give the antidote too so that's
a shredder and Eric will have
uncontrollable power actually how the
hell would that work cause he already
rich guy who has been made stupid richer
I hand over all my decision-making to
this evil metal looking guy i sir you
still didn't seem to answer any
questions about how that horrible
disease all came from a giant building
obviously owned by you my giant scary
middle guy will answer all those
questions uh I don't really know what to
say I'm always playing about ruling the
world and now that I have it I don't
really have any plans for it I'm evil to
lose touch but the turtles escape and
they stop the shredder on top of a
building kind of like every turtle
climax that's been done with the
shredder the more I think about it
and even though need to feed him they're
all falling to the ground a Raphael
makes a big confession I'm certainly
gonna take years of resentment and build
it up into being the world's greatest
psychiatrist and analyze myself and
explain everything about my character in
this couple of seconds and everybody
already know yeah whatever can we just
eat pizza and say outdated catchphrases
cowabunga tella bunga inti
yeah Sebastian we have been really good
for me in movies because I usually see
talking turtles and talking records all
the time and our videos can see them now
oh you could see me for the true beauty
I really am
forgive me money for drugs either works
this is just to read boom Singh chai God
shine I come on up agile yes goodbye
Jay come on I'll keep crying in the next
movie I even know where to get an actual
talking brain
you